welcome to the livestream I'm in a very
very different location today I have a I
guess I guess you would call it a
speaking gig tomorrow and thus I am
coming to you from a different location
and my lighting is horrible the
background is not ideal let's see if I
get this lighting is very very harsh
let's see if I can improve that a little
bit Wow
that is uh that is bad yeah that's a
little bit better we're just gonna try
to deal with it I have something that
may shock some of you I actually agree
with a policy decision that Donald Trump
has made although I think that he's
doing it for the wrong reasons and
without understanding one bit of the
underlying geopolitical implications of
what he's doing I'm gonna get to that in
a moment I also do want to talk about
the latest news about Senator John
McCain there's really a lot of things to
discuss so I'll jump right in this is a
live stream if this is your first one we
are able to communicate you and I and
the best way to do that if you have a
question or a comment that you want me
to read or answer or address is through
the super chat super chat is enabled
using the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window if you have a question
or comment it will be read sometimes
super chat is used to get me to say
funny things sort of seems like a waste
of time and money to me but by all means
if that's what if that's your gig then
by all means feel free but yeah super
chat is on use it and I'll dive into
those questions soon new members and
patrons who choose to sign up during
this stream will get live shoutouts and
thank-yous we made big progress on my
last live stream and getting towards
1800 patreon pledges and I will talk
about that a little bit more later but
david pakman.com is the place for
memberships patreon.com slash david
pakman show is the place for patreon
pledges obvious trolling and hate will
get you banned and I have since since
the last livestream I've deputized yet
another moderator because the trolling
has really sort of gotten out of hand
and the moderators have been not only
empowered to but encouraged to ban and
block people as they see fit
bearing in mind of course that we are
trying to encourage open and diverse
debate you will not get banned because
you are right a right-winger you will
get banned if you do obviously stupid
hateful or annoying things in the chat
okay
John McCain we learned that he was
undergoing surgery for a blood clot in
his eye we have since learned that he
has a malignant cancerous brain tumor he
has brain cancer it's very very early to
really say much else in terms of
prognosis treatment or anything like
that what we can be sure of is that
because he is a member of the US Senate
he is going to get absolutely the best
care available to him and that's a good
thing I don't say that sarcastically it
would be great if we could make it so
that more people in this country could
get the care that everybody deserves
that John McCain is going to get and we
wish him the best increasingly a voice
of reason although I don't agree with
him on all issues or even remotely close
to that but increasingly a voice of
reason among Republicans lately and that
that is that and I'm sure we will have
time to report more on that upcoming
okay
so what do I get agree with Donald Trump
about Donald Trump made the decision
today well and possibly the decision was
announced today the decision appears to
have been made about a month ago to end
the u.s. program where we are arming
anti-assad rebels in Syria okay and just
as I talked here I'm gonna try to soften
the lighting a little more because it is
very very harsh I think hopefully that's
a little bit better and I agree with
this idea I have been against I have
been skeptical of and in many cases
against this picking sides by the United
States Pentagon intelligence community
executive branch whatever right this
picking sides within countries where we
say let's arm this rebel group
or that faction or whoever because we
have a really bad track record of in
terms of who we support and who we back
and even when we end up supporting or
backing the quote right side it often
ends up backfiring because allegiance
has changed those groups can be defeated
and it's very common that the weapons we
send overseas or down to Latin America
or wherever end up being used against us
or our allies so I actually believe
Donald Trump made the correct decision
if you were to come to me today and say
David you criticized a lot of what
Donald Trump does and a lot of what
Donald Trump says in blah blah blah
what's the best thing you think Donald
Trump has done other than the failure to
repeal the Affordable Care Act I think
that this is something that we would be
on the list Donald Trump is going to
stop arming the anti-assad rebels in
Syria now do I think that it's good
because I want Assad to prevail in power
obviously not I think it's good for the
reasons I said but this is yet another
example of how Donald Trump is doing
everything that Vladimir Putin would
want him to do and for those who say if
there's a quid pro quo in exchange for
Donald Trump being helped into office by
Vladimir Putin's Russia Vladimir Putin
hasn't gotten much and to that I say you
could not be more wrong it started with
trying to ease sanctions on day one of
his presidency it started before the
presidency with effectively getting the
Republican Party to soften its its
position on Ukraine and Russia it
includes the constant lying about
meetings with Russian actors it it
includes trying to return these two
Russian compounds to Russia it includes
spilling classified information that we
obtained from our ally Israel to Russian
diplomats one of whom is a suspected spy
recruiter for Russia in the oval office
and this is now yet another decision by
the Trump administration that Vladimir
Putin absolutely loves the Kremlin
Russian interest
been wanting the us to stop arming
Assad's opposition since it started
under President Barack Obama so while I
agree with the decision does anybody
think Donald Trump understands what's
going on in Syria to any degree beyond
remembering one or two talking points
that someone whispered into his ear
before he went onstage for a debate
rally press conference whatever the case
may be no there's no evidence that he
knows anything about what's going on and
this is yet another way in which Putin
is getting absolutely everything he
wants now this might be confusing to
some of you who say what David are you
so is this good or is this bad I agree
with the decision it is yet more
evidence that Donald Trump is fumbling
around in the dark just doing what it is
that flat Amir Putin wants him to do or
benefits from so we're gonna dig into
this in more detail tomorrow at its core
this is about not getting involved in
another country civil war as is being
mentioned in the chat one can make the
argument that this is really it's Isis
related so the u.s. is involved whether
you believe that or not that doesn't
mean the US should be involved so I
agree with the decision I believe it is
part of the total acquiesce acquiescing
that we are seeing and it's maybe not
even acquiescing it might be something
Trump doesn't mind doing with regard to
Russia and this is all while we're
finding out about this 8th person that
was in the the Trump Tower meeting with
Donnie jr. and Jared Kushner and Paul
Manafort and the the Russian lawyer
Natalya vessel NEETs kaya and Rob
Goldstone and the whole thing the 8th
person is a widely known alleged Russian
money-launderer
who maybe I don't even wanted to get
into this entirely now and we'll dig
into it tomorrow but yet again one of
these cases where the more we learn the
worse it seems and now there really
seems to be a money-laundering component
to whatever it is that appears to have
gone on with Russia so we're gonna be
talking about all of this stuff tomorrow
there's also a really interesting
article in let me tell you where it is
in the hill which reports that Donald
Trump jr. is absolutely miserable and
can't wait for Donald Trump's presidency
to end and in fact he allegedly can't
wait for these four years to be over
which has pretty significant
implications about Donald Trump's
re-election chances and we're gonna talk
about that tomorrow as well as I
continue let me make another tweak here
to my lighting just to see if we can
soften it even more because it's it is
harsh folks it is harsh and I apologize
for that I think that that keeps getting
somewhat better although it's hard to
tell completely okay I'm gonna jump into
the Super chats in a second here before
I do that let me remind you of course
that we are trying to weather the storm
the destructive storm of the YouTube
advertiser boycott we've lost
eighty-five percent of our revenue we
were at point one on this graph earlier
in the year we fell two point two at the
beginning of the YouTube ad boycott it
looked like things were recovering
around 0.3 and ultimately we are at a 85
@n 85 percent deficit in terms of
YouTube ad revenue and as a result we've
got to make that up okay one of the ways
that we're trying to do that is via
membership so you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership members will
get instant access to the commercial
free all access a website section I
guess we would call it as well as
instant access to the bonus show if the
normal rates of six dollars a month or
$60 a year strike you as high no problem
I've got just the thing for you it is a
coupon code
I voted 17 I've voted 17 all lowercase
all one word that will give you a 40%
discount and on that note I want to say
a big thank you to Mitch Jones who has
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership Mitch you are a great
American actually I don't know if Mitch
is American it doesn't matter I was
channeling Sean Hannity there
second I guess also big thank you to
Bill Tuttle bill Tuttle has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership and
more thank yous forthcoming and of
course if you don't want to deal with
this entire membership thing skip the
entire thing go over to patreon.com
slash david pakman show and make a
pledge you can pledge as little as a
dollar a month my challenge to you
during this stream is let's get to 1800
patrons okay we're at 1783 patrons my
goal it would delight me if we could get
to 1800 we only need 17 patrons that is
only seventeen one dollar a month
donations you can donate two bucks if
you want you can donate five or ten or
twenty or some people they're doing
fifty or even a hundred but you don't
have to just $1 a month
gets you on record and let's see if we
can do that and thank yous forthcoming
there as well all right let's jump into
the Super chats a lot of super chats to
get caught up on Jacob ball sent a
five-dollar super chat saying the bright
lights had you glowing like a holy
figure yeah this is not so it's
nighttime here on the East Coast in the
United States and as a result I'm
supplementing lights with with
additional lighting now I wonder if I
just turn it off what does that do for
us Wow now I'm just basically in the
dark I mean is that better would people
prefer that I do this is this not I
don't know man this is weird I think I
need the lights this is this is just too
dark okay I apologize about it I
apologize I will try to do better next
time 0 1 3 2 1 3 2 cent a $6 and 66
cents super chat saying David are you ok
agreeing with Trump makes me worry that
you've got some kind of brain thing I
told you I agree with the substance of
what Donald Trump is doing the reasons
he's doing it are part of the same
corruption that we've seen for a very
long time
gr cent to $5 super Chad were two trees
and each had a person speaking
underneath their limbs and one of those
people was packed easy I would stand
under the packed easy trees II okay well
not sure what that's about but thank you
appreciate that our rich row path a
corpus AK has sent a $2.00 super chat
saying why does the wall fam Domino's on
Lexington Street suck I assume a retro
is referring to Waltham Massachusetts
where I went to graduate school at
Bentley University I have not been you
know actually I remember the last time I
went to a Domino's Pizza because I
became violently ill two hours after
going to that Domino's Pizza and it was
December 30th of 1999 and the reason I
remember is it was clearly a very
traumatic experience but because it was
the day before a New Year's Eve party it
was December 30th of 1999 and as a
result of becoming violently ill as a
result I believe of the Domino's food on
December 30th 1999 I didn't have a
particularly fun December 31st that year
and I never went back to Domino's and
that's it so a retro I could not tell
you anything about the Domino's Pizza on
Lexington Street in Waltham
Massachusetts a $2.00 super chat from
game fire 74 words of wisdom to someone
consumed with Trump hatred you're asking
for words of wisdom for someone consumed
with Donald Trump hatred I would say
focus on hopefully I don't know what I
would say it I'd have to think about it
focus on the issues I don't know
Eric Inglot has sent a $10 super chat my
super chat yesterday if you remember it
I don't think I did a super a live
stream yesterday must have been Monday
but anyway Eric Inglot says my super
chat yesterday if you remember it may
have been misunderstood it is obvious to
any sane person that Fox is very
right-wing my grandparents are just much
more so absolutely love your show all
right well listen I
I don't want to go back and rehash the
entire thing did I do a live stream
yesterday is that true I could have
sworn that it was two days ago look at
my calendar uh I did do a live stream
yesterday go figure people on the stream
seem to have a better grasp of my
schedule than I do
okay well very good Eric I'm glad we
were able to clarify that Frank macwrite
has sent the twenty dollar super chat it
was obvious Trump was just lying for
votes but why is it so hard to fix
healthcare it still feels like they're
more concerned with the profits of the
insurers it feels like they really hold
the cards any thoughts of course I mean
of course that of course they are we
have a system which is completely
inefficient it adds layers of medical
billing bureaucracy pricing bureaucracy
and profit none of which serve the
consumer of healthcare in any way and of
course it's because the health insurance
industry has an insane amount of power
and an absolutely stunning amount of
power and they are more concerned with
the profit it's the profits of the
insurers because everything that is
being proposed in these harebrained and
failed American Health Care Act versions
who knows how many versions there have
been at this point I guess kind of for
to house and to Senate versions or
something every one of the versions
would be good for insurance companies
and bad for consumers so yeah you're
spot on Frank there's been a $1 Super
chat that came in I don't know who it's
from and the message has been retracted
so if a super chat comes in and we don't
know who sent it and we don't know what
they said did it really come in well we
still got the dollar so in that sense I
guess it did Mark's Tanner's has sent a
five British pound super chat I'm
looking forward to a wise guy in the
White House movie can we have a debate
on the movie title by the way the
lighting is fine all right well I'm glad
people are okay with the lighting I look
forward to the movie as well D Knight
has sent a to u.s. dollar super chat
Russian translator equals non official
operative cover yeah I talked about
today so for people who don't know what
this is about and I see that we've got
patreon pledges and new members coming
in and I'm gonna get get through those
thank yous in a second for people who
don't know what I'm talking about Donald
Trump it's been revealed had a second
meeting with Vladimir Putin at the g20
in Germany and it was an undisclosed
meeting news of the meeting leaked and
ultimately it was confirmed by the White
House because it was obviously true and
a number of people in the room sighs and
one of the most sort of stunning facts
about it was that Donald Trump had this
meeting with Vladimir Putin this
conversation with Putin without his own
translator it was only speaking through
Vladimir Putin's Russian translator and
this goes against a lot of diplomatic
protocol in these situations and as I
mentioned on the program today
Vladimir Putin does speak English it's
not great English whether he could
discuss politics in detail with his
English maybe not right that's a fair
critique but if this was the short non
non-serious completely meaningless
meeting that it was made out to be
then Putin could have had this meeting
with Donald Trump in English and they
opted not to do that and Donald Trump
speaking through a Russian translator
and this is a common thing that you
bring in the translator that may or may
not be necessary and translator is a
pretty common operate operative cover
for intelligence operatives and listen
we're talking about Vladimir Putin
former head of the KGB this is not a
dumb guy and Donald Trump just has
absolutely no idea ever
what it is that he is stepping into Paul
McGinnis puppetry has sent a $2 super
chat saying would pence be worse than
Trump well
pence would be more effective than
Donald Trump number one number two pence
would be much less scandal-ridden and as
a result would would be more effective
merely by virtue of that in addition to
just being a you know a smarter
legislator and when it comes to that and
Mike Pence is much more of an ideologue
than his Donald Trump so I think that
Mike Pence
would be far more dangerous than Trump
in most ways with the exception that
with the exception that if the thing
starts getting bad for Trump and I think
you know what it is that I'm talking
about if it really starts to look like
Trump's going to be taken down I would
not put it past him to take some kind of
erratic military action to try to
increase his approval rating
I don't believe Mike Pence would do that
so in that in that one way I believe
that Trump is quite a bit more dangerous
than pence game fire 74 has just sent a
$7 and fifty three cent super chat do
you and Pat have comments that are on
camera that don't get published it would
be nice to get some bloopers or
unfiltered commentary well the
commentary that you get is not filtered
in any way I mean we don't it's not like
we do run throughs and do stories a few
different ways and then you know decide
which one is safest for broadcast I mean
the show is done once and that's it you
know as far as whether there are on
camera unpublished comments not really I
mean basically we start the recording
process when we're starting the show and
we end it when we're done so there's a
very little that's filmed that isn't
part of the actual show yeah anyway
that's that's what I'm going with
because I don't want you finding all the
bloopers let me get back to some
thank-yous we are trying to we're
basically asking for your support right
we have been hit really hard we actually
determined today that our channel is in
the top 1% of YouTube channels in fact
it's it appears to be in the top point 8
percent of YouTube channels we are
approaching 400,000 subscribers and that
puts us pretty squarely certainly in the
top 1% of YouTube channels and
unfortunately because of the YouTube
advertiser boycott which which is going
to result in a huge it already has
resulted in a huge redistribution of ad
dollars to major media outlets we're
getting crushed we've lost 85% of our ad
revenues so I want to continue the
program
unchanged unfettered with absolutely you
know not needing to do anything
differently not needing to reduce
programming staffing or studio anything
like that and so what we're doing is
we're using two platforms one such
platform we're using is called patreon
patreon is super easy you just go to the
website and you click the red button
that says become a patron and you put in
some amount of money that you can pledge
on a monthly basis if it's only a dollar
that's fantastic right we estimated that
at most if people were watching all of
our YouTube videos every month we were
making thirty to fifty cents off of
those individuals if you pledge $1 it
might feel like you're not doing much
you're actually making up the lost
revenue for you and two other of our
subscribers if we can just get to three
percent of our audience making some kind
of financial contribution this problem
is over and we can just end it and
forget about it and get back to our
production schedule that's all we're
talking about and this may come as a
shock to some people but we estimate
that only half to one percent of our
audience actually supports us
financially and that actually really
angered a viewer of ours Chris who wrote
in last week and said that he is
absolutely stunned that despite having
nearly four hundred thousand YouTube
subscribers we have not yet reached two
thousand patreon contributors and I said
to Chris listen but if I'm not looking
to take people's last dollars here you
know after all this is independent media
it's important but we're not looking to
get people's last dollar so if you don't
have a dollar to contribute then by all
means don't write but if you do have a
dollar to contribute and many of you do
we've done the audience surveys please
consider making that dollar contribution
when you think about twelve dollars a
year is that really going to change your
buying power is that really going to
change your budget for most of you it's
not but it makes all the difference in
the world if we can just
get three or four percent of our
audience to make that pledge so keep
those pledges coming and thank yous will
be upcoming in the meantime I do have
more new members to thank and we do have
a coupon code which gets you a 40%
discount off of membership members also
get access to the members only bonus
show every day we do a broadcast show
which is free to everybody and we also
we also do a bonus show just for our
paid subscribers you'll get instant
access to that if you sign up on our
website so some of the new members that
have signed up during the live stream
are jerko morovich jerk over yerko
morovich thank you for signing up at
david pakman.com slash membership we
also have a brand new member kaitlyn
Cusick kaitlyn Cusick has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership Rodney
boring Rodney burring has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership all
these folks using the 40% discount code
and also a Whitney mink Whitney mink has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership appreciate every single one
of you please keep those new memberships
and patreon pledges coming by the way if
we get I just want to throw this out
there if we get to 1,800 patrons by the
end of the livestream today I will
create just for you and announce a 50%
discount code for membership and it will
only be available to those of you on the
stream so let's see if we can make that
happen and on that note let me jump back
in to the questions coming in through
super chat West and East 1024 has sent
in a $5 super chat with no question or
comment thank you very much denied has
sent in a $2 super chat odds of Trump
juniors Russian translator being NOC
what is NOC I actually don't remember
what NOC is NOC abbreviation what is NOC
it's on the tip of my tongue huh don't
know what that means what is what is NOC
can somebody tell me
and OC hmm I don't know was he and I'm
gonna feel so stupid when someone in the
chat explains to me what NOC is just
waiting for someone to say it and then
I'm gonna feel like an idiot which
happens somewhat often on the program
actually anybody NOC non-official cover
right it's quite possible yeah I mean
it's it's very very possible and we've
talked about that we've talked about
that in the context of the Trump Putin
previously undisclosed meeting
sandanista has sent in a five Australian
dollar super chat great David is a part
of the 1% now I'll have to unsubscribe
since the 1% is screwing the rest of
YouTube alright I guess I I know that
it's a joke I don't know exactly what it
relates to I'm not I guess I'm kind of
supporting my own show yeah Frank
macwrite $20 super chet concerning the
YouTube ad pocalypse have you
communicated with any other channels
different from yours a video game or
drumming channels that are dealing with
the same issues I think YouTube is
retargeting the owner or earnings yeah a
lot of different types of types of
channels have been hit hard there's two
reasons why I'm talking mostly about
news and politics channels and and they
relate you know not I'm not insulting
anyone gaming channels are great and
makeup channels are great but there's a
couple things going on one political
channels have been hit harder than other
channels because of the quote sensitive
nature of the topics we discuss things
like Russia and Syria so political
channels have been hit harder and given
the Trump era I don't know that it's as
dangerous for gaming channels to not
make as much money as it is for
independent sources of news and
political analysis to not make as much
money this is not an attack I want to be
super clear I've got friends who have
music channels and gaming channels and
all sorts of stuff with peace and love
everybody's fantastic and all that stuff
you know trophies for everyone who's
doing their thing but I think that right
now is a particularly disastrous time
for any force that will make it more
difficult to have
of independent news and political
analysis so yeah a lot of different
people have been affected political
channels are getting crushed absolutely
crushed Chris cull has sent a $2 super
chap saying thanks man well thank you
Chris
eat KitKat double J has sent a $2 super
chat saying step up I'm broke and I have
a membership and patreon well thank you
eat KitKat jayjay there are lots of
people I know and listen I get it right
I I watch i watch stuff and i hear
appeals for funding and the entire thing
and it's easy to say listen I don't I
just don't do that somebody else will do
it blah blah blah when you look at the
revenue chart for our YouTube channel
this is a problem right this is not me
doing anything out of my mom's house I
mean other than this live stream but the
show I do from a studio we have staff we
have production expenses we distribute
this program for free to 200 community
radio and television stations and
DirecTV and Dish Network on free speech
TV all of whom would not be able to
afford to pay for those costs so we
front them because I believe it's so
important to make the show available on
all of those media outlets but with 85%
less youtube ad revenue it becomes
pretty damn difficult okay so to
everybody who's contributing like eat
Kit Kat JJ and everybody else thank you
thank you I I appreciate it and
hopefully there will be more thank yous
upcoming on the program okay let me go
through a few other things I mentioned
some of this yesterday but I know that
we get different people on every stream
so let me mention a couple of other
things Dave Rubin the host of the Rubin
report will be joining me for the hour
as Larry King used to say next Tuesday
we've never done this before instead of
doing a normal show okay next Tuesday
the entire broadcast hour which is 50
minutes right we've got ten minutes
commercials in the broadcast our the
entire broadcast hour all four segments
will be an interview with Dave Rubin it
will be deep it will be deep reaching
and wide-ranging I don't know what to
call it we're gonna talk about a lot of
different things and we have a thread on
our reddit discussion forum which if
you're not participating and you
absolutely should be nearly 4,000 of our
viewers and listeners are we have a
thread called Dave Rubin will be on the
show for the full hour on Tuesday
questions and we have 70 suggestions so
far four different things people want me
to ask Dave Rubin some of them relate to
his assertion that liberalism is
basically a mental disorder
progressivism some relate to classic
liberalism some relate to his his views
on Donald Trump a lot of questions
coming in for Dave Rubin if you have
questions for Dave Rubin then
participate send those questions and you
can submit them through that thread at
david pakman.com slash read it ok after
we do this one-hour interview I plan to
go to the audience and ask you did you
like the one-hour interview or would you
rather us do seven stories and a short
interview okay
I'm not ideologically married to one
idea or the other I think that there is
some value to doing some longer form
interesting interviews and I look
forward to trying it with Dave Rubin
we've tentatively got one or two other
of these long-form interviews scheduled
and I think it's going to be absolutely
tremendous and I don't know how else to
say it I think it is going to be very
very interesting and I look forward to
your suggestions and I also look forward
to your feedback now along these lines
we've got a lot of other very
interesting stuff planned for you I've
mentioned that we do have a planned our
summer vacation is happening in the
second half of August ok and during that
time we are going to be releasing and
subsequently some really interesting
I call them deep dives there's a deep
dive playlist on our YouTube channel now
some people call them long-form pieces
call it whatever you want we have right
now a piece that is effectively done on
the so called violent left now it's
becoming popular and right-wing circles
to say oh the left is so violent the
left is violent the right is not violent
but the left is debunked okay
our intern Brian in conjunction with
producer Noah Ferguson have put together
a tremendous video which I have narrated
and we are going to debunk that we are
working on a video about classical
liberalism and there's going to be a
couple components to the classical
liberalism video one is going to be you
might think you know what classical
liberalism means but it doesn't mean
you're progressive but you don't like
social justice warriors okay so we're
doing a deep dive into what classical
liberalism is and then we're going to
evaluate is classical liberalism
actually progressive hint no it's not
and I think people are going to like
that that's gonna be a really good piece
then the next stage and I hope to have
some of these ready for you in time for
the vacation we're going to be doing a
piece debunking the concept that
socialism has never worked if you know
me you know I am NOT a communist I am
NOT a socialist I aligned with
Scandinavian democratic socialism which
even though it's called democratic
socialism it's not actually socialism
but it's really important if we're going
to talk about socialism we need to
understand its history and to say Oh
socialism has never worked that's sort
of a bad start to the conversation so
we're gonna separate socialism from
communism we're going to talk about
whether it's true or not but socialism
has never worked hint it's not true and
then we will be able to do a deeper
analysis that's gonna be really good
we've got a deep dive coming up on voter
suppression the right likes to talk
about and Trump talked about it today at
his election integrity committee lunch I
mean with just whatever thing it is and
the right legs to talk about in-person
voter fraud dead people voting quote
illegals voting as a real problem it's
not a problem right it's not a problem
and we're gonna we're gonna do a big
story on what is
problem which is voter suppression and
then later on in the summer we will have
a deep dive into race and IQ which will
also consider the recent controversy
involving charles murray the bell curve
and sam harris although it will go way
beyond that and we will also we will
also be doing a piece this is actually
this is arguably the most ambitious
thing we've ever done we have a 12 to 15
part miniseries in the works it's not
yet been finalized how it'll be divided
a 12 to 15 part miniseries on critical
thinking what is critical thinking basic
epistemology logical fallacies cognitive
biases that people should be aware of
could be one of the best things we will
ever have produced by the time it's done
but it requires a lot of time we produce
a 5 day a week show and then once that's
done we've got all these long-form
pieces that were working on and we need
to research and we need scripting and we
need narration and we need fact-checking
and we need video animation and that
component so this is why this is why
this is a problem the 85 percent
reduction in YouTube ad revenue if the
stuff I just mentioned to you sounds
like [ __ ] and you don't want to see
us do any of that stuff don't make a
contribution right forget about it don't
don't contribute if those sound like
valuable endeavors that would add
something positive to the conversation
and what's out there about a lot of
these issues consider making a pledge of
a dollar or two a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and on that note
I want to send a big league thank you
to Herbert Holmes who has just pledged
five dollars per month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show I want to send a
huge thank you to Jeremiah Jones who has
just pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show that
gets us to 1785 patrons if we get to
1,800 folks please we can do this if we
get to 18
hundred during the stream I will create
and announce to you a one-day only 50%
discount code off of membership just for
you just for people on our stream okay
and I would never even dream of
shortchanging our members who have been
signing up while we've been talking here
you can sign up for membership and get
all those great member benefits at a 40%
discount by using the coupon code
I voted 17 on our website membership is
all the rage all the kids are talking
about it these days and I want to say
thanks to Sharon Kennedy as well as
chris Hawkins and Ivan Newton and David
Weissman all of whom has signed up just
while we've been chatting here at david
pakman.com slash membership all right a
lot more questions that I want to get to
in the super chat next one is from Wow a
lot here says ikan Alice has sent the
$10 super chat saying thank you David
thank you says he always appreciate your
support marks Tanner's has sent a ten
British pound super chat I live three
miles away from a wall built 2,000 years
ago politics has been going on here
before and since then social care has
been learnt and accepted over that time
all right very good thank you very much
mark victor Savelle has sent a $10 super
chat in hindsight of the YouTube ad
pocalypse would you say you had relied
on ad money too much and when do you
consider the catch-up complete knowing
that you'd like to expand the show more
much love listen that's a fair critique
which is we were overly reliant on
YouTube ad revenue we were way less
reliant on YouTube ad revenue than many
other channels and that's because I was
always I'm worried with every ad revenue
source re with every revenue source that
it could go away at some point right
there's been problems with the Amazon
affiliate program there can sometimes be
problems even just processing payments
through membership whatever the case may
be so we my running of the David Pakman
show as a business
is it's quite conservative and that's
why we did not go out of business as a
result of the YouTube ad boycott but it
is going to impact us in terms of our
future plans and growth if we don't if
we don't sort of solve that and you know
when would I consider the catch-up
complete my goal would be if we replace
all of the lost revenue we now are
completely independent of YouTube ad
revenue and then we can use that as a
new jumping-off point for further growth
new shows more programming a network of
programs whatever you know I think I
think the sky is sort of the limit when
it comes to this xx Jamaica has sent a
five dollar super chat ask Dave Rubin I
presume they mean why he can't walk and
chew gum at the same time like why can't
he criticized the right please hold his
feet to the fire I'm going to talk to
him about Trump there's no doubt about
it and we are going to get into that I
promise you
xx Jamaica west and east 1024 has sent a
$1 super chap KLM has sent a 2 British
pound super chat Thank You Marcel 84
Marcel has sent a $21 super chat that
makes it edging out Frank macwrite the
biggest single super chat of the evening
is there any way to donate with Bitcoin
or aetherium I am actively working I am
actively working with a web developer to
see how we can start to accept a theory
I'm sorry Bitcoin okay and interestingly
our system works on a platform that has
an addon for accepting Bitcoin so my
sense is it's not a huge task to do that
it's my goal Marcel to be able to accept
Bitcoin xx Jamaica has sent a
five-dollar super chat I would recommend
watching youtuber nightmare fuel on
legitimate criticism of Dave Rubin
thanks for your work alright I will
check that out I am interested in
seeing all critiques all critiques of
Dave Rubin before the interview I think
it is gonna be a very very interesting
interview and I hope that you will give
me your honest feedback when when that
video publishes ok on that note it is
getting incredibly warm in this room
because I can't run the air conditioner
while I'm on because my mic would not
like it I am going to end this stream
we've got a great program tomorrow
thanks to everybody who signed up for
membership thanks to everybody who
contributed on patreon help us do this
thing help us do this thing because this
is not good this is not a good situation
I will talk to you tomorrow